[Music]
hey what is up guys i'm kid bhd here and
welcome back to dope tech i'm bringing
it back so previous episodes were all
thematic where they would be based
around a group of things with one theme
or maybe just one huge piece of dope
tech but there's been so many
things that have come out in the past
year and that are about to come out that
are all dope tech but don't necessarily
get their own video so this is my way of
sort of collecting them in one place i
know some other people have their sort
of favorite tech of the month or of the
season or quarter or whatever you want
to call it this is my version of that
this is dope tech it's a video series to
showcase the most impressive bleeding
edge super high end or just straight up
awesome tech that makes its way to the
studio that doesn't necessarily get its
own video it will all be here so this
may feel a little rapid fire but that's
what happens this time of year when
there's so much impressive stuff coming
out so
let's get right into it
so i'm going to start
with this guy so this is called the asus
zenbook pro duo it's pretty wild i'd
describe it as a sort of almost dual
screen laptop you can probably already
see what i mean so it's already a big
desktop replacement high-end laptop it
has a 15-inch
4k oled display which right off the bat
there's not a whole lot of laptops like
that it has an intel 9th gen 8 core cpu
rtx 2060 graphics a terabyte ssd 32 gigs
of ram and a ton of high speed ios you
can see no card reader but both full
size usb and usb type c but the high end
specs aren't why this is dope tech it's
of course this crazy form factor so
first of all you can see this hinge is
pretty unique i like unique hinges this
one unfolds the laptop into a sort of a
propping it up off of whatever surface
you're on and that serves several
functions one it gives you a better
typing angle and it's gonna need that
extra cooling for this massive second
screen it has on the bottom half it's
like the macbook pros touch bar
went and eight
five or six
other
touch bars and then
went to the gym and just got super huge
uh it's gigantic to the point where it
is another
4k ips display itself it's not full uhd
but it is 3840 across by 1100 tall and
it's coated in this anti-glare finish so
it's matte like apple's touch bar to
avoid glare from overhead lights and
things like that which makes sense since
it's at this angle but it also appears a
bit dimmer than the main display since
you're never really looking directly at
it it's always at this sort of off
sideways viewing angle and it's also
super smooth and soft to the touch it is
a touch screen
unlike the glossier top display just
really nice to touch anyway okay so what
is the second screen for what does it do
so essentially the best thing it does is
act as
a second display so windows actually
sees it as two different displays but
you can do the same thing on both
screens if you want which is kind of
trippy but the best stuff you'll do with
it will come with window management so
you can get one chrome window up at the
top while you have spotify open on the
bottom and maybe a twitter window on the
other side and all the window snapping
and everything that windows does will
work the same you can snap left or snap
right go full screen and there's an
extra layer of asus software added to
let you do things like switch apps
between the screens or pin the launcher
or full screen apps across both displays
full screening across both displays like
i said it's kind of weird looking but it
does work
i just think this is the least often way
that you'll use it unless some apps
happen to scale perfectly maybe you can
imagine having adobe's lightroom about
the top with most of the ui elements
where they normally are but just the
film strip of all your photos at the
bottom or maybe adobe premiere about the
top but just the timeline on the bottom
screen the way i found myself using it
most often was just using the regular
apps and stuff like i normally do at the
top and then having something like
spotify or maybe twitter or something
like a files app that i can just sort of
mindlessly keep there but i'm not using
on the main screen then i sort of have
my setup going in
i don't know it's kind of great and then
asus has a couple other features built
in to make this layout more useful like
a dock that you can pin apps to and you
can have it remember app layouts with
multiple apps so you can just hit one
button and it loads your whole layouts
for all your apps again i'm into it i
think it could be worth it now the
question for someone considering buying
this laptop right now is is it worth
moving the keyboard all the way down to
the bottom edge and crunching the track
pad from this widescreen laptop all the
way over the corner in this little
postage stamp size i don't know i guess
most of the time you're using something
like this you'll have a mouse with you
and bonus the heating vents or cooling
vents on the side will actually
heat your hand with the mouse
fun fact but i just figure people will
find like the perfect use case for
something like this to work out in their
workflow like a gamer playing a game up
at the top and having their twitch
stream
live chat and discord on the bottom
screen just certain things are going to
work perfectly with this top and bottom
screen setup that are going to make it
worth the compromise of that tiny
trackpad laptops of the future might be
similar to this or they might get rid of
the keyboard entirely for some people
it'll just be one giant screen with a
folding display in the middle that just
folds shut like a clamshell
we're not there yet and they call this a
laptop of the future and i think for a
lot of people it is but if you want to
get this right now
you can it starts at less than three
thousand bucks so i'll have a link to
everything i talk about in this video
in the description
okay next up is another dual screen
thing
kinda it's the lg v50
and it's dual screen case now the phone
by itself wouldn't have made dope tech
gonna be perfectly honest it's a pretty
under the radar phone but it has 5g now
and it still does have that quad dac and
the headphone jack but otherwise a
pretty standard issue smartphone for a
thousand bucks but what they do have is
a fascinating implementation
for doubling your pixels
on a smartphone
and you guys know i'm a kind of a sucker
for pixels so i guess they basically
said screw it since we can't make a
folding phone right now what we can do
is put some pins on the back of an
existing phone
and then make a case
that takes those pins and has a display
in it and turns it into
a dual screen
phone so you pop it into this case you
hit the dual screen button and now you
have a dual screen phone now still i
don't know how much i'd use something
like this it's no doubt drawing extra
power from the phone it'll make your
battery life a bit less but honestly the
way it works it works surprisingly well
like it's much smoother than i expected
so you can go ahead and open different
things on each screen and then the dual
screen feature lets you swap what's on
each screen put one of the screens to
sleep etc they've really thought this
through it's not as automatic as an
actual folding phone but that's of
course not really what this is you can
even go sideways with it you can watch a
full screen video on one screen while
you text or tweet or do whatever you
want on the other kind of looks like a
nintendo ds when it's sideways like this
it's an interesting concept and then it
folds over completely backwards if you
want it to which deactivates the back
screen so now if you just want to use
the phone normally and leave it in this
case you can do that
um folding phones i guess can't really
do that but i just love how much they've
thought this through and it does one
thing i think better than any folding
phone does in my opinion which is just
like that
the springs the the weight of that
build quality it's built well i don't
know i just think this is just so
interestingly well considered the cutout
up here for the earpiece to pass through
if you make a phone call with it the
fact you can flip it over completely
it's funny it brings me back to
you know what it brings me back to when
htc
made that dot matrix case for the htc
one m8
back in the day that was one of the i
think that is actually the first video i
ever shot on a red camera
fun fact
okay so next up are
these guys right here so these are
sony's new wireless noise canceling
earbuds they're called the
wf-1000xm3 the name is still terrible
but they are absolutely worth your
consideration i think they're my new
favorite wireless earbuds right now so
with these new totally wireless earbuds
there's a couple different types of
earbuds wearers that i think i've sort
of picked up on one would be the
powerbeats pro type of user where you're
getting them specifically to work out to
sweat in them run around shake your head
a lot that type of thing and the other
is like the airpods type of user where
you're just having the convenience of no
wires taking some phone calls listening
to music pretty chill
and these fall somewhere in between i
reviewed sony's over ear headphones not
too long ago and they turned into my
favorite headphones to fly with period
so now that i've experienced those i
wouldn't necessarily buy these to fly
with but they do an impressive job at a
lot of things for earbuds so first of
all they're comfortable which is like
priority number one for me for earbuds
when they sit in your ear
is that they're comfortable and these
are and they just sit in your ear just
like this they have touch controls over
physical buttons which takes a little
bit of getting used to but i actually
prefer that on earbuds so you don't have
to be pressing them into your ear just
to press one of the buttons
and there's a lot of stuff you can do
with it in the sony app like remapping
controls from the right earbud to the
left earbud they're very customizable
and they have auto play pause so when
you take it out of your ear whatever
music's playing stops and i love that a
lot of these are doing them now with the
proximity sensor in the earbud and it's
quick it stops pretty much as soon as
you take it out and plays as soon as you
put it back in
and they also have multiple device
connectivity which is funny because the
headphone versions of these that i
reviewed not that long ago didn't have
that
these do and overall i'm gonna say that
they are the best sounding wireless
earbuds that i've heard that i've tried
so far they're on par with or better
than the jaybird runs great mids
not really shrill highs and pretty solid
bass and again in the sony app you can
change the frequency response if you
like it to be bassier the noise
cancellation element is kinda minor just
because you're getting most of your
noise isolation from the passive seal
created by the earbuds anyway but they
do a little extra work with the
microphones to quiet those constant
background noises so if you're in a car
or in a train or a plane or something
like that these are nice the case to
these isn't too bad you know somewhere
between airpods and powerbeats
pocketable but just barely but it quick
charges the buds which is nice and it's
matte black so i guess i have to like it
and it does instant pairing with this
nfc just by touching it to the back of
your phone that's tight the one downside
the big downside really is that these
are not
water resistant so if you want to work
out in these you'd still want to get
something like the power beats so you
can actually sweat in them and they'd
stay in your ears better but
other than that not a whole lot of bad
things to say about it we're also
expecting possibly noise cancelling
airpods to be a thing pretty soon
actually we may see that by the end of
2019 so if you're waiting and sort of
holding your breath for better air pods
that might be interesting to you but if
you're not one of those people these are
definitely a pair that you should check
out they're 100 worth your consideration
okay
sony rx100
mark 7.
i just wanted to bring this up for one
specific reason so there are a lot of
really great in-depth videos on the new
rx100s on youtube i'll link those below
this obviously isn't that but i've been
an rx100 fan since literally the very
first one it's been an awesome compact
photo camera and then it's stepped up
its game as a 4k video camera over the
past couple years articulating lcd
screen better color science eye tracking
auto focus and it's always been such a
great compact form factor and it's so
very modular it's got a pop-up oled evf
it has a pop-up flash it has the custom
ring that you can map to whatever you
want
but it's always been missing
one thing
a mic jack
and this version mark 7
finally has a mic jack honestly it seems
like every time canon releases something
sony is always ready with something
right up their sleeve like waiting to be
released it seems like this is another
one of those things it sort of came in
the middle of the cycle they had done it
on the year pretty regularly for a while
until this one but they finally threw a
mic jack in the rx100 mark 7 which i
think makes it that much better of a
little point-and-shoot vlogging camera
definitely worth checking out the
competition back and forth between canon
and sony over the years has actually
been really fascinating to watch it
almost seems like canon enjoys shooting
himself in the foot and leaving out
individual features that would make a
camera amazing sony does not have a
habit of doing that at this point
all right
i don't know if you saw it over here
before but it was in a previous shot
this is the newest member of the
logitech mx family it's a logitech mx
master three so it just came out but
logitech has let me use this guy for the
past week and i gotta say i like it a
lot in appearance it is a pretty minor
update from the mx master 2s it looks
pretty similar but it has some minor
adjustments the battery indicator for
example is higher up so you can see it
even when your hand is on the mouse the
forward and back buttons are a bit more
separate so they're easier to press
without looking
and the sort of a hex design is now
these more clear ridges and clean and a
couple other really subtle things the
main difference is the scroll wheel is
now much improved and the software is
super customizable so now you can map
the same buttons for different functions
in different apps so for example the
sideways scroll wheel for me and final
cut that will scroll left and right on
the timeline but in photoshop it'll
change the brush size and in the browser
it'll just scroll left and right and of
course the one main thing that i was
sort of hoping that they would do all
along actually with the last mx master
is they've switched over
to usb type c and for no other reason
and the fact that i can use a bunch of
my existing cables now that's really
satisfying so i've really enjoyed using
this editing with this mouse using it
every day it's one of the few pieces of
tech that i can say i've consistently
had the same product or version of the
product in my workflow for a very long
time so the best mouse that i've used
for the past couple years just got
better
gotta love that
continuity all right so last but not
least is the microphone that i'm
speaking into
right now
this it's not even new it's just new to
me and i newly love it it's the shure
sm7b so you've probably heard of this
guy already if you're in the podcasting
world but i've been doing video for so
long and i've been using a shotgun
microphone specifically by sennheiser
for so long that now that i'm doing
podcasts and that i'm in this audio
world i'm discovering this whole new
world of audio gear so this mic this one
specifically might be the most popular
one out there it's the one joe rogan
uses it's the one a ton of radio
stations have used
probably asmr videos it's
out there it is made specifically for
vocals both in the way it's tuned for
frequency response and what noises it
isolates
and in the way it's built it's solid
metal it's rugged just about everything
about it one pro tip i can give besides
getting it on an arm and getting the
microphone as close to your mouth as
possible for the best sound is to get
some sort of external amplification like
this this is a cloud lifter if you
haven't already heard of it it's often
sold with the shure sm7b which happens
to be a very quiet microphone by itself
if you go straight into a recorder which
is what we tried first on episode one of
our podcast but we found these we got
them they do a great job of amplifying
and now the microphone sounds much more
lively and more open it just sounds
better so you plug the microphone via
xlr into the cloud lifter you plug the
cloud lifter into your recorder and you
get the amplification that way and it's
great
so i just figured i'd give a shout out
to the mic which is a central piece of
the podcast and give a shout out to the
podcast while we're at it but either way
that has been it that is episode one
of dope tech and i'm i'm super open to
your suggestions for both format and all
sorts of other ways that we can make
these episodes better i think they're a
lot of fun but i think we're going to
have a lot of other stuff to show you so
other ways that we can do it well are
welcome in the comments section below
but again like i said all the links of
all the things i talked about are also
below
and that'll be it thank you for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace